that theme of inequality we're going to
ask our estranged children getting a
fair go at school no matter their
background or postcode because when it
comes to education the debate is usually
framed around dollars or how to arrest
the declining academic results of a
scrounged school students in
international rankings but the
importance of access to education is not
lost on the man you're about to meet
he's a fellow maths nerd so brace
yourself
Eddie burr was the head maths teacher at
cherrybrook Technology High School in
New South Wales tomorrow he'll be
delivering this year's Australia Day
address in his home state it's the first
time a classroom teacher has been asked
to do so it's not just an inspiring
teacher he's also an internet sensation
his YouTube channel mr. woo tube has had
over 10 million viewers take a look on
the bottom you've got four sorry take
that back 16 sine squared theta cos just
another x squared and then instead of DX
I'm going to write for cos theta D fear
so via I've done almost substitutions so
far so good I thought we weren't allowed
to show pornography at this time of
night he joins us now
Eddie woo how are you Eddie and it's
great to be here right to have you here
my friend we were just watching a little
bit of woo tube then what is woo true
where did it come from and what is this
sensation it has become well a couple of
things we're tube is what happens when
someone who appreciates dad jokes names
a YouTube channel nice but secondly it's
just what's come out of the fact that
I'm a teacher and I work in a public
school very proudly and I realized that
we have technology now that allows us to
amplify the value of that learning in
places all around the world you would
never guess so for the last five years
I've been recording my lessons during
normal class time so in the middle of a
lesson you know I have to stop because
little Johnny gets called to the deputy
principal's office and that's just what
gets recorded and put online for free
started as a service for I think for a
student of yours who was ill and had
missed a few lessons it's gone wild how
many people check out whoo - it's really
hard to keep track of actually it
constantly changes and more than a
hundred thousand people that I last
checked are just getting the regular
updates
to me speaks a lot to the fact that
mathematics while it gets a bit of a
name on the street for something that's
only for a certain few I think it's
something while hard everyone wants to
understand you know it's compulsory for
so many years and I think most people
are interested in so what is this thing
that I've been forced to learn for so
long what does it actually mean so of
those hundred thousand regulars obvi ten
million hits you've had are they all New
South Wales or Australian based high
school students in Utah who are they
where do they come from
well what surprises me is that even
though it's just literally what the
Sydney comprehensive school is teaching
on a day day basis because as you know
Adam mathematics is a universal language
LM a brother more than half of the
people who are watching are not even
from Australia they're from all over the
map in fact I looked recently and you
can mouse over and see there's people in
Paraguay there's people up in the Arctic
Circle
everyone wants to learn now me it turns
out any was not that good in mathematics
in his early years of high school what
do you think of this insight why is that
because it breaks the stereotype that we
assume all Asians are good at math it's
demonstrated understand you're good at
English and history definitely my
favorite subjects so what what the
success of blue tube so far what what do
we take from it what does it actually
represent you've said one thing that
that mathematics if you if you make it
beautiful people will come to it it's a
subject that can reach out to people to
me does it does it make a deeper point
that you're creating a vessel here
that's that's education for all
regardless of where they're at school or
what access to immediate resources they
have for me it's hugely important that
these people come from everywhere and
it's really valuable that you know no
matter where you are or where you live
or what your background is that if you
have access to education and access to
learning resources there are almost no
limits on what you can achieve and I
remember a couple years ago I was at the
University of New South Wales and I was
talking to a small group of pre-service
teachers and after I'd given my
presentation I sat down and a girl who
was just a couple of rows behind me said
hey Eddie look I never thought I'd ever
meet you but I'm from Orange and back in
the school that I was at no one talked
mathematics extension to that's the
highest level of mathematics there was
in a class for it there's no teacher
willing to do it so she do it did it by
distance and just by watching those
videos it was one of her there
subjects and now here she is at UNSW
changing power mathematics teacher for
me that's astonishing it cinders from
Jaina Xander the potential of new
technologies to provide educational
experiences for people outside of the
traditional classroom it I don't think
it's something that can be overlooked
oh no and it's it's coming really really
fast I mean you'd know about the flipped
classroom where the things that I used
to do in class when I was at school now
kids do those at home and they actually
do interaction with teachers in the
classroom rather than writing things
down off the board and all that boring
stuff which is making school a whole lot
more interesting but also there are
things like in New South Wales Aurora
College which is in fact a selective
school which is available to students on
the internet so you'd leave stay in your
public school but you can still if you
pass the selective schools test access
all this extension work even if your
school is a million miles away from any
kind of selective campus and I think
we're going to see more and more of that
and it's very exciting because I think
one of the things we've had happen in
Australia is we have concentrations of
disadvantaged kids in some schools and
concentrations of advantaged kids in
other schools and we know from research
that that compounds the disadvantage of
the disadvantaged and so if we can go
back to having more opportunities to
more kids whatever kind of school
they're in then everybody benefits
can I ask you Gary is this is this a
sort of technology that could
substantially shake up the model this is
very different from when you and I went
to school my friend well things continue
to change in this direction on a my sort
of nerdy dreaming at the potential for
reform here maybe you're dreaming I mean
over the last 20 or 30 years we have
come across many kind of transfer made
he of educational programs that suddenly
got to do wonderful things for everybody
and just kind of taken a little bit of a
grain of salt that maybe these are for
advanced maths students ones who are
doing well I think it's level two or
something in New South Wales what 10% of
the population of students is this
advanced maths can it be good for
everybody is it going to actually help
kids that are meddling in maths or doing
the what they call nets for dummies I
mean yes yes let me ask any there
quickly so are there lots of other
not necessarily at the extension - level
of mathematics or in subjects outside of
mathematics on online as well are you a
bit of a sort of a digital island look
the first thing I've got to say is Gary
I have to take issue with the phrase
maths for dummies because I don't
believe anyone in my classes in my
schools are dummies and in fact I think
that mathematics is for everyone and in
fact I great I take great pride over the
last couple of years I had one calculus
can be taught to every - every student's
like we can teach advanced calculus yeah
12 electors to every student in year 12
I would argue that I think more people
will understand tactile lists then
actually realize it because mathematics
in terms of calculus is just the
mathematics of things that change and
everyone who's driving their car down
the highway and is watching their fuel
indicator just sort of but I I know my
car I know where it goes they're
actually from calculus that talking
about driving the other car was a fuel
game I disagree have interest in it but
they can still absolutely know and I
also take issue with the it's it's mess
you call it formats for dummies this
maths for everyday life it wasn't best
for dummies I mean that's a derogatory
way of saying that's I guess but you
know what I mean I mean other people use
it all the time yes I mean the fact that
they were there oh they're a class there
were classes given at different levels
of you remember at school there were
there were times here her classes and
yes it may be advanced maths or whatever
but you didn't quite get it in class you
had YouTube at home you could go back
and actually have a look at somebody
else explaining it - just in a different
way but you understand that a lot but
whatever things my daughter who is an
English teacher tells me with her
classes where she's teaching Shakespeare
to kids who have no cultural capital in
Shakespeare at all is that when they can
what look at her videos where she
annotates and talks about does what she
would have done in the classroom but now
that's on YouTube they can learn it in
their own time and if they don't
understand something they can go back
and go over it and go over it which they
can't do in the classroom
Garry let me ask you something here
because you have an opinion on the
different factors that do affect the
potential of students to achieve in high
school and it's it's it's an opinion
that's a bit radical for some people to
take on in particular the connection
between a chai
a social economic status background and
their potential to achieve so can you
talk us through your thoughts in that
area and we'll try to unpack that I
guess so what's what I what's what I'm
saying is that the there's a lot of lots
of people who talk about SES being the
most important predictor of student
outcomes or performance and what is
associate onic status just it can be
anything along the way it can be family
income combined with family occupation
education mums education it's all very
nebulous really been there's been a kind
of narrative around since the 70s that's
all about SES and we have to do is just
give more money to poor schools and then
bingo everything's solved we're going to
reduce inequality and there's not going
to be no inequality for outcomes that
the main predictor over the main
influence on how well kids - is ability
mobility from which they get from their
parents and it's modified a bit by the
schools but a built some some authors
claim that ability explains 80% of the
variation in in performance at schools
so so to put it to put it crudely Gary I
think you're you're saying that once
you've got a group of kids out of school
given their cognitive abilities and
where they're at that's gonna be the
main determinate the educational system
you put around on the type of teachers
the type of schools can only do so much
does that argument have much truck with
you Jane correct it doesn't it doesn't I
don't think anyone's saying bingo give
more money to schools and we'll have no
more inequality I think that's really
not I think that's what any ski is all
about it no it isn't it certainly
doesn't say bingo it says we might
improve and close the gap that is
absolutely growing the fact that you'll
probably never get rid of inequality
completely because of people's differing
ability there's no reason to say what we
won't bother at all will increase the
inequality between students that is not
an argument the point about this is
poverty itself it's becoming clearer and
clearer
has an impact on a child's cognitive
development so there is now neuro
scientific research which is saying that
kids who come from families who earn
twenty five thousand dollars a year have
6% less quartel development then kids
who come from families where they earn
one hundred and fifty thousand dollars e
this is some new research by Scott Noble
it's Noble and Sal I think I wanted to
get that out correctly
ah and so what our problem is is if kids
are born into impoverished environments
Gary to some extent is right they are
behind the eight-ball from the beginning
and schools can only do so much
what we need is really early
intervention for free prenatal pre no no
no no no but prenatal intervention for
pair from others to work with their
literacy variability or factors in you
really do have to let me finish what I'm
saying I let you so the prenatal stuff
interventions to help mothers with their
problems we know who the kids are who
are likely to fall through through the
cracks before they're born we could
intervene early and we also know from
worldwide research that that has a real
effect on their educational potential
when they get to school because you're
building their social capital early
thank you can I ask you a quick question
I mean there are some people who spent
twenty five thirty thousand dollars here
putting their kids in certain private
school environments does your research
also suggests that really the schools
and the fees and the faith-based or
educational philosophy there don't
really make all the difference those
kids are just gonna get what they get
anyway well one of the big problems with
the school sector debate in Australia is
that the lack of data I mean New South
Wales has been very reluctant to give
any data to anyone about so you can
compare sex school sectors I Queensland
as well the only place that are allowed
to look at the data comparing sectors is
formed survey data which is not
incomplete and for the Victoria and when
you look at Victoria and Australia why
you do find differences between the
sector's you do find is expected either
been in school sector does slightly
better or more than slightly better than
the government school system in the
Catholics are in in between it's not a
huge effects maybe three or four or five
eight are score points and then you can
argue Rosetta is that a lot or not very
much the half
glass-half-full argument is it's four or
five eight are points pretty cool or is
it not I mean I think it's it does
reflect on that that independent schools
do add value to a certain extent but the
effect is quite moderate it's going back
to what we said before about that can't
change kids very much but you can there
are better ways of worse ways to teach
kids
let me bring me in here for a second
being in the pretty in the private
sector your organization's often have to
choose people coming out of high schools
out of school environments you know as
your as your workforce oh no a few years
ago you sort of inverted your model what
was your exposure and experience there
so I mean we we had the traditional
model you look for graduates really good
results from from uni you know went to
these fabulous schools had played rugby
probably that was the sort of buyers
that came through through corporate
Australia and for one of the years we
actually turned around we refused to
look for people from those elite SACEUR
the circumstances from those privileged
outcomes and we actually hired a
graduate from regional university with
only very average results from from
university the thing that actually sort
of made us interested in him was the
fact that because he couldn't actually
get a job after University he actually
threw wool bales for six months just
because he wanted to work
he was the best ever graduate we have
why because he had empathy his work
ethic was there he care about what he
did you you talked loved his job he was
so grateful for it was we've had
circumstances where we've had people
from really privileged backgrounds from
the that their their guys from private
schools at the universities played rugby
all that sort of stuff
and couldn't cope when we actually had a
crisis because they didn't have the
resilience still work through those
really tough time Eddie this is the
thing about taking more than just the
curriculum teaching teaching resilience
teaching a bit of intestinal fortitude
how do teachers deal with that day today
how do you how do you how do you not
teach so brilliantly you've got kids who
are used to being spoon-fed by a
brilliant teacher I think the important
thing to understand here is first that
this is both teachers and parents
responsibility and one of the things
that's been really challenging and as a
parent I say this as well my kids are
four seven and nine so I'm very attuned
to what they
and what only I can give them as their
father teachers are constantly being
given this extra responsibility and I
think it's something that we are willing
to take on because we know it's
important for children and we know how
decisive it can be for children and
their their academic outcomes and their
character and citizenship outcomes if we
say look it's more important to me than
just getting really top marks to be able
to say well do you understand what these
Marta for do you know how to use them
for the sake of society and that's
social justice understanding that aspect
of education is well why holistic
education is kind of what makes a school
really tick that's why we needed to
first range of school because Gary
there's some research isn't there that
if you have putting it very basically if
two kids go to university same course
same mark while I went to st. lardy DARS
and one I went to knuckle high from day
one the kid from knuckle high starts to
do a little bit better than the kid from
the cosseted well-supported maybe over
resourced environment is that correct a
little bit correct it's been at that
idea before that the idea has been
around for a long long time that the
private school kids are spirit feeling
when they get to uni they kind of
collapse and they fail but the evidence
is pretty there isn't much evidence on
this but it's also quite limited and the
effect of the difference between private
school kids and in our government school
kids when they get to university or
first year was that he can do first year
really it's quite small two or three
points the major determine on how well
kids do where they drop out of
university or whether they complete
their degree is there a task or so
you've got a really high eight-hour
score you you almost invariably complete
your course in a lower a task or you
tend to you've got a high probability of
dropping out or in completing happening
your plate and the where you school
sector you went to is quite a small
effect on all this it's a complicated
mishmash of effects inning in inputs and
outcomes human children in terms of that
resilience you know people people who
are expending significant amounts of
money on their half a million dollars to
put some kids through private schools
now for the ages that is it's the high
school experience well some say it's
great though and it teaches my kids
certain values
it makes it there in a better
educational environment that if they're
in the local high school others suggest
that's just a big waste of money well
I'll just take Gary's argument that that
you know people say that putting more
money into poor schools won't you know
isn't really worth it it won't make any
difference well it's really it's really
interesting what you said that the
argument is that we put more money into
poor schools and bingo there'll be no
Louis schools I said poor schools not
sure what a poor school is looks like
these days you come from poorer
backgrounds scary cause I ask you to let
me finish I really want a partner
the point about this is if money really
makes no difference to how cute reduce
the school the research well I do
private schools need so damn much of it
not just from parents who may be
persuaded for marketing reasons to pay
it but from governments and I rest my
case we should be delivering money via
neede and if we are delivering money
which is of no use and doesn't help
anyone
we shouldn't be delivering this people
cynically give me Gary we are almost
glad at home people sitting hunting in
jail which had another 15 minutes for
this as of next week the job drums going
to a 45 minute for any very quickly have
you written your acceptance speech for
Friday if hypothetically you do when
your award look it's a bit ridiculous to
be I'm suffering from a terrible case of
impostor syndrome right now I mean being
written down a few words which my wife
is assured me I will definitely not need
to use but they're there just in case
you can fit in some small reference to
trigonometric differentiation I'd love
it deal you might have noticed someone
will refine selfie that's taken hold in
social media of light this is great
because you can now ask Google to find
your portrait in art museum somewhere in
the world by their Arts and Culture app
the app allows users to submit a selfie
photo it uses facial recognition
technology to then find a match among
its international database of artworks
some uncanny spitting images others are
a bit of a stretch so depending on the
angle you've been watching so far the
summer drum with me Adam Spencer or
perhaps st. Paul by a Bitola mayor
Montaigne
yeah or maybe you think I look more like
Colonel George Watson as painted by John
Singleton Copley or maybe a militia man
holding a burqa mile which is a drinking
vessel by friends ha that one we've got
the time for tonight but I'd like to
thank our panel Eddie whoo or as I like
to call him hon rack ye on self-portrait
look this just shows even Google thinks
all Asians look the same Ming long also
known as portrait of a lady by Okada so
no tsukai do you like to like this
absolutely it's just wrong ethnic whose
good friends often mistake him for
Francis roar'd and Hastings by Sir
Joshua Reynolds
you're looking very thoughtful there
Gary better hand on the chin you know
old and finally Jane or should I call
you Adrian I know me the likes women get
facial hair but I'm complaining to my
electroless art and culture hat download
it and have a go yourself that's all we
got time for good luck again on Friday
Eddie whoo and we'll see you again
tomorrow night until then good night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]